A row class of 100% of the page width.
Well, this seems pretty necessary because we want each row of columns to take up
as much space as they can.
So we will check that off because we need it.
That means that we won't need a row of one twelfth of the page width
because we're going to cut up the row into columns.
Are we only going to need a column of one twelfth of the page width?
No.
In fact, we're going to need columns of everything between one twelfth and
12 over 12 page widths.
By defining columns for any size between 1 over 12 and
12 over 12 page widths, we'll be able to create content and
columns that takes up as much or as little of the grid as we'd like.
This means that of course this last answer can't be right because only
creating these three classes won't give us enough flexibility.
It's worth noting that the fraction 1 over 12 is equivalent to 8.33%,
2 over 12 is equal to 16.66% and so
on all the way up to 12 over 12 being equal to 100%.
You'll be using these numbers soon.